a lot of what you'll learn in
differential equations is really just uh
different of dif different bags of
tricks and in this video i'll show you
one of those tricks and it's it's useful
beyond this just because it's always
good when if maybe one day you become a
mathematician or a physicist and you
have an unsolved problem some of these
tricks that solve simpler problems back
in your education might be a useful
trick that solves some unsolved problem
so it's good to see it and if you're
taking differential equations it might
be on an exam so it's good to learn so
we'll learn about integrating factors so
let's say we have an equation that has
this form let's say this is my
differential equation
3
x
y i'm trying to write as neatly as
possible
plus y squared
plus
x squared
plus
x y
times y prime is equal to 0. so the
first especially since we've covered
this in recent videos whenever you see
an equation of this form where you have
some function of x y and then you have
another function of x and y times y
prime equals zero you said oh this looks
like this could be an exact differential
equation and how do we test that well we
can take the partial derivative of this
with respect to y and we could call this
our this function of x and y m
so the partial of that with respect to
y so m
the partial with respect to y
see it would be three x
plus two y
and if this function right here
that expression right here there that's
our
that's our function n
which is a function of x and y we take
the partial with respect to x
and we get that is equal to 2x
plus y
and in order for this to have been an
exact differential equation the partial
of this with respect to y would have to
equal the partial of this with respect
to x but we see here just by looking at
these two they don't equal each other
they're not equal so at least
superficially the way we looked at just
now this is not an exact differential
equation
but what if there were some
factor or i guess some function that we
could multiply both sides of this
equation by that would make it an exact
differential equation so let's call that
mu
mu
so what i want to do is i want to
multiply both sides of this equation by
some function mu and then see if i can
solve for that function mu that would
make it exact so let's try to do that
so let's multiply both sides by mu
and just as a simplification
mu could be a function of x and y it
could be a function of x it could be a
function of just just x it could be a
function of just y
i'll assume it's just a function of x
you could assume it's just a function of
y and try to solve it or you could
assume it's a function of x and y if you
assume it's a function of x and y it
becomes a lot harder to solve for but
that doesn't mean that there isn't one
so let's say that mu is a function of x
and i'm going to multiply it by both
sides of this equation so i get mu of x
times
3 x y
plus y squared
plus
mu
of x
times
x squared plus x y
times y prime and then what's zero times
any function well it's just going to be
zero right zero times mu of x is just
going to be zero but i did multiply the
right hand side times mu of x and
remember what we're doing we're this
this mu of x is when we multiply the
goal is
after multiplying both sides equation by
it we should have an exact equation so
now if we consider
this whole thing our new
m
the partial derivative of this with
respect to y should be equal to the
partial derivative of this with respect
to x so what's the partial derivative of
this
with respect to y
well if we're taking the partial with
respect to y here
mu of x which is only a function of x
it's not a function of y it's just a
constant term right when you take a
partial with respect to y x is just a
constant or a function of x can be
viewed just as a constant so
the partial of this with respect to y is
going to be equal to
mu of x
times
we could just say times 3x
plus 2y
that's the partial of this with respect
to y
and then what's the partial of this with
respect to x
well here we'll use the product rule
so we'll take the derivative of the
first expression with respect to x mu of
x is no longer constant anymore since
we're taking the partial with respect to
x
so the derivative of mu of x with
respect to x well that's just just u
prime of x or mu prime not u
mu prime of x
mu is the greek letter it's for the m
sound but it looks a lot like a u so mu
prime of x times the second expression
x squared plus x y
plus
just the first expression this is just
the product rule mu of x
times the derivative of the second
expression with respect to x so times
ran out of space on that line
2x
plus y
and now for this this new equation that
i multiply i multiplied both sides by mu
in order for this to be exact these two
things have to be equal to each other so
let's just remember the big picture
we're kind of we're saying this is going
to be exact and now we're going to try
to solve for mu so let's see if we can
do that
so let's see we have
on this side we have
mu
of x
times 3x plus 2 y
and let's subtract this expression from
both sides so it's minus
mu
of x
times 2x plus y you'll see a lot of
these differential equation problems
that get kind of hairy they're really
just a lot of algebra
and that equals what do we have left
i'll write it in yellow that equals
i think i'm going to run out of space so
i'm going to do a little bit lower that
equals just this term right here that
equals
mu prime
of x times x squared plus x y
and let's see if we factor out a mu of x
here we get mu
of x
times
three x plus two y
minus two x minus y
is equal to
mu prime of x the derivative of mu with
respect to x times x squared
plus x y
now we can simplify this so we get
mu
of x
mu of x times what is this 3x minus 2x
is x
2y minus y so x plus y
is equal to and i'm just going to
simplify this side a little bit
is equal to mu
prime
of x let's factor out an x here and i'm
the reason why i'm doing that is because
it seems like if i factor out an x here
i'll get an x plus y so
so this is mu prime of x times x
times
x plus y
right
x times x plus y is x squared plus xy so
that's why i did it and i have this x
plus y on both sides equation which i
will now divide both sides by so if you
divide
both sides by x plus y we could maybe
assume that it's not zero we get that
simplifies things pretty dramatically we
get mu
of x
is equal to
mu prime
of x
times
x
and now for just the way my brain works
i like to rewrite this expression just
kind of in our operator form where we
write instead of writing it u prime of x
we could write that as d mu
dx so let's do that so we could write
mu
of x
is equal to
d the derivative of mu with respect to x
times x
and this is actually a separable
differential equation in of itself this
kind of a subdifferential equation to
solve our broader one we're just trying
to figure out the integrating factor
right here so let's divide
both sides by x so we get
well we get mu
over
x over x i'm just doing this is just a
separable equation now is equal to d mu
dx
and then let's divide both sides by mu
of x and we get 1 over x
is equal to
is equal to 1 over
mu that's mu of x i'll just write 1 over
mu right now for simplicity times d mu
dx
i'm actually going to go horizontal
right here multiply both sides by dx you
get 1 over x
dx is equal to 1 over mu of x
d
mu
now you could integrate both sides of
this and you'll get the natural log of
the absolute value of x is equal to the
natural log of the absolute value mu et
cetera et cetera but it should be pretty
clear from this that
x is equal to mu or mu is equal to x
right they're identical if you look at
both sides of this equation there you
can just you know change x from u and it
becomes the other side so this is
obviously telling us
that
mu of x
is equal to x right or mu is equal to x
so we have our integrating factor and if
you want you can take the
anti-derivative of both sides with the
natural logs and all of that and and
you'll get the same answer but this is
just a just by looking at it by
inspection you know that mu is equal to
x because both sides of this equation
are completely the same
anyway we now have our integrating
factor but i am running out of time so
in the next video we're not going to use
this integrating factor multiply it
times our original differential equation
make it exact and then solve it as an
exact equation i'll see you in the next
video